.
Heute geht es um alles.
Ich bin schon nervös.
Während zwei Jahren haben sie
auf diesen Tag hingearbeitet.
Die Symbolik ist schon stark.
Bonjour. Bonjour.
Heute ist die grosse Abschlussprüfung
für die jungen Diplomaten.
Der lang erwartete Moment.
Es ist schon krass.
Ah, da passiert was.
Voila.
- Merci.
* Feierliche Streicherklänge *
* Dramatische Streicherklänge *
Hold on!
Are you at the Swiss club?
C'est la, c'est la.
Este es mi machete,
Spickzettel, auf Deutsch.
Du bist Krisenmanager.
- Yes, are you here?
Yala, yala.
Diplomatie ist in der Schweiz
nicht besonders beliebt.
Man kennt uns nicht gut. Das ist
vielleicht auch unsere Schuld.
And a toast together.
(Ignazio Cassis) Auf Sie zählen wir
während der nächsten Jahrzehnte.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Samira will Diplomatin werden.
Sie macht
die zweijährige Ausbildung beim EDA,
dem Eidgenössischen Departement
für auswärtige Angelegenheiten.
Zusammen mit ihrem Ehemann
ist sie heute aber Gastgeberin.
Ihre Mutter und ihre Geschwister
kommen heute zum Abendessen.
Geht's gut?
- Sehr, und dir?
Ich wurde zwar fast von
einem anderen Velofahrer überfahren.
Ah, von einem Velofahrer. Immerhin.
Samira
ist eine von fünf jungen Personen,
die auf ihrem Weg in die Diplomatie
begleitet werden.
Seit zweieinhalb Monaten
ist sie schon in der
Diplomatinnen-Ausbildung des Bundes,
dem Concours diplomatique.
Samira und Edgar
sind seit zwei Jahren verheiratet
und leben genau so lange
auch zusammen in dieser Wohnung.
In Burundi, im Osten Afrikas,
haben sich die beiden kennengelernt.
Tu veux deja prendre la casserole?
Also, mangiare, mangiare.
Danke.
- Bitte.
Merci, Edgar.
C'est un plaisir. Merci pour
nous rejoindre. Merci, merci.
Guten Appetit.
- Guten Appetit.
No, we never did that.
Eine Zucchetti ist bitter.
Ja, nein, das nervt mich auch immer.
Ich glaube, es gibt nichts,
das mir wichtiger ist als Familie.
Ich bin extrem froh und dankbar,
dass ich eine so super Familie habe.
Sie ist offen.
Sie ist offen für alles.
Sie ist gradlinig.
Sie hat einen sehr harten Kopf.
Wenn sie etwas anpeilt,
dann zieht sie es durch.
Ich denke, es hilft mir
allgemein im Leben sehr,
dass ich einfach so sein kann,
wie ich bin.
Und dass für mich immer klar war,
dass das okay ist.
Ich denke grundsätzlich schon,
dass das auch in der Diplomatie
von Vorteil ist.
Klar muss man sich
an gewisse Positionen halten
und kompromissbereit sein.
Z.T. muss man Positionen vertreten,
die einem nicht entsprechen,
je nach Situation.
Aber ich denke, du kannst auch dann
dich selber sein.
Der Hintergrund von Samira
hat sicher auch eine Rolle gespielt.
Dass es so viele Möglichkeiten gibt,
so viele verschiedene Leute.
Einfach diese Offenheit.
Das hast du sehr mitbekommen.
Sei es im WG-Leben
oder mit der Kultur von Ghana,
dem Hintergrund deines Vaters.
Verschiedene Kulturen und Länder,
das interessiert Samira.
Sie hat
internationale Beziehungen studiert,
dann acht Jahre in einer Organisa-
tion für Friedenspolitik gearbeitet.
Eine gute Basis
für die diplomatische Ausbildung.
Für mich war es immer
die Herausforderung:
Beruflich wäre es super,
aber privat ...
Das wird sicher schwierig.
Was heisst das für den zukünftigen
Partner, die zukünftige Familie?
Ciao, amore, ciao.
Guten Start morgen.
Danke.
- Mach's gut.
Tschüss.
Du hast den Schlüssel, oder?
Die grösste Herausforderung
wird zweifellos sein,
ein Gleichgewicht zu finden
mit der Begleitperson.
Die Karriere der Begleitperson
mit einer Karriere zu vereinbaren,
bei der man
alle vier Jahre weg muss.
Die Karriere des anderen
wird unterbrochen -
das ist
eine ganz grosse Herausforderung.
(Frau) Man spürt das Gewicht kaum.
Es ist gut verteilt.
V.a. auf die Hüfte.
Auch der Berner Jonas Belina
möchte Diplomat werden.
Das bedeutet nicht nur für sein Leben
eine grosse Veränderung.
Mein Spatz. Ja.
Auch das Leben seiner Partnerin
Katrin und seiner Tochter Celestine
ändern sich wegen Jonas' Berufswahl.
Der Physiker
und die klassische Gitarristin
haben sich in den USA kennengelernt.
Ich komme aus Berlin
und die Kultur ist schon anders,
als ich es gewohnt war
von den USA und so.
Aber es ist ... ja.
Ich habe ein Quartett gegründet mit
drei anderen Gitarristen aus Bern.
Das ist meine
kulturelle Inspiration, sozusagen.
Diese Landschaft ist für den zukünf-
tigen Diplomaten Jonas v.a. etwas:
Heimat.
Ich habe schon
eine starke Verbundenheit.
Auch in Zukunft,
egal, wohin ich gehe,
ich werde immer irgendwie
in der Schweiz zu Hause sein.
* Ein Telefon klingelt. *
Katrin Endrikat.
Guten Morgen. Wer ist dort?
Oh, die spanische Botschaft,
oh, wow!
Schönen guten Morgen.
Wow, das klingt ja unglaublich.
Ja, super! Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Ich wäre sehr interessiert.
Okay, super,
vielen Dank für Ihren Anruf.
Und ich bin wirklich ganz erfreut.
Adios,
adios.
Wow, krass!
Ich habe gerade einen Anruf bekommen
von der Sekretärin der spanischen
Botschafterin - genau - in Bern.
Sie hat von mir gehört
und wollte fragen,
ob ich ... für Events bei ihnen
spanische Musik spielen könnte.
Und ... Ja.
Bist du stolz?
Ja, ich bin auf alle Fälle
sehr glücklich,
dass Katrin gute Möglichkeiten hat,
Gitarre spielen zu können,
Konzerte und Auftritte
geben zu können.
Das ist doch ideal.
Also, das passiert normalerweise ...
Keine Ahnung, das ist ...
Das ist schon toll. Ja.
- Du findest das auch gut, wie?
(Katrin) Ah ja?
* Sie schnalzt mit der Zunge. *
Wir haben es hier oben wirklich gut.
Wir lassen sie kurz überholen.
(Frau) Thank you.
- You're welcome.
(Mann) Thank you.
Celestine? Setzt du sie hierhin?
Okay.
Hier ist gut.
Ja, jetzt gibt es Essen,
mein Schatz.
Die Schweiz wird bald nicht mehr
das Zuhause der jungen Familie sein.
Zur Diplomatenausbildung gehört ein
praktischer Teil auf einer Botschaft.
Jonas reist in einigen Monaten
nach Argentinien.
Es ist extrem wichtig,
dass es für sie gut ist.
Da stehe ich
schon sehr in der Verantwortung.
Wir haben uns das sehr gut überlegt.
Es ist ja wirklich
eine grosse Entscheidung.
Aber gleichzeitig
ist es auch wirklich schwierig,
bei allem vorherzusehen,
was es bedeutet.
Ich meine,
intellektuell versteht man es,
aber rein emotional,
wie es dann tatsächlich sein wird,
kann man nicht voraussagen.
Sobald Jonas seine Ausbildung
abgeschlossen hat,
arbeitet er alle vier Jahre
in einem anderen Land.
Wegen dieses Rotationsprinzips
wird das Umziehen zum Lebensstil.
Ich tendiere dazu, bei Entschei-
dungen eher zu viel nachzudenken.
Und meine Erfahrung
hat eher gezeigt,
dass ich hin und wieder
mehr auf meinen Bauch hören sollte.
Wow!
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Es ist schon krass, oder?
Nein, nein, das war alles Gletscher.
Nachdem er weggeschmolzen war,
gab es einen See.
Und wenn wir das
mit heute vergleichen,
erkennen wir
nochmals eine starke Veränderung.
Hier sieht man noch
ein grosses Eisfeld.
Das ist jetzt
beinahe weggeschmolzen.
Es ist unglaublich,
wie schnell es geht.
Das Aufhalten des Klimawandels
ist definitiv das,
was mich in die Diplomatie treibt.
Jonas' Weg in die Diplomatie
ist ungewöhnlich.
Er ist Naturwissenschaftler
und vielleicht bald Diplomat.
(O-Ton) Die Premiere:
Ein US-Präsident empfängt
einen Schweizer Bundespräsidenten
im Weissen Haus zu einem Gespräch
über Freihandel und Diplomatie.
Maurer trifft Trump -
für das EDA,
das Eidgenössische Departement
für auswärtige Angelegenheiten,
ein diplomatischer Grosserfolg.
Bundesrat Ignazio Cassis und seine
360 Diplomatinnen und Diplomaten
schaffen genau dafür:
Die Interessen der Schweiz
sollen in der globalen Politik
eine wichtige Rolle spielen.
Wir wurden eingeladen. Ich glaube,
darauf dürfen wir stolz sein.
Wirtschaft, Kultur und Frieden.
Die Schweiz soll auch in Zukunft
im Ausland gehört werden.
Diplomatischer Nachwuchs
wird also benötigt.
Es ist nicht einfach
nur etwas nettes Politisches,
damit wir sagen können:
"Wir haben auch Diplomaten."
Dieses Netzwerk ist für die Schweiz
überlebenswichtig.
Wieso habe ich die nicht?
Ach, wie kann das sein?
Warte mal.
Ah doch, da ist ... Hey.
Ich glaube, ich habe es gefunden.
Auch Jean-Baptiste
ist einer der wenigen,
die für die diplomatische Ausbildung
ausgewählt wurden.
Der Traumberuf Diplomat ist für ihn
stark mit Nigeria verknüpft.
Ich bin hier im Hintergrund.
Das war meine erste Erfahrung
beim Bund, beim EDA,
dieses Praktikum.
Da kam die Idee, vielleicht einmal
in die Diplomatie zu gehen.
Das ist das Abschiedsfest
des Botschafters.
Er hat mich sehr motiviert,
es zu probieren.
Er hat mir gesagt: "Jean-Baptiste,
das musst du probieren,
das ist sehr spannend.
Das musst du machen."
Bereits als Kind lebte Jean-Baptiste
während drei Jahren in Ruanda.
Sein Vater arbeitete dort,
in Ostafrika, als Entwicklungshelfer.
Afrika,
das hiess für Jean-Baptiste:
viel Zeit mit seinem Adoptivbruder,
endlich Haustiere halten können,
Klassenkameraden aus aller Welt
und viele Freiheiten.
Und das trotz der
politisch schwierigen Situation.
Als wir 1990 in Ruanda ankamen,
brach ein Krieg aus.
Rebellen kamen aus dem Norden.
Und plötzlich schickte Frankreich
Truppen nach Ruanda,
um die Regierung zu unterstützen.
Als Kind fand ich das voll cool.
Wir realisierten nicht,
dass Krieg war.
Du hast null Ahnung,
was ein Krieg ist, was passiert.
Ich erinnere mich
an den 1. August.
Die Schweiz hat dort
ein Fest organisiert - natürlich.
Mit Bündnerfleisch und Raclette,
wie es Tradition ist.
Mein Bruder und ich
mussten uns verkleiden
und allen, die ankamen,
Schokolädchen verteilen.
Wir sollten ein wenig mithelfen,
die schweizerische Gemeinschaft
in Kigali zu unterstützen.
Mein Bruder und ich
waren so lächerlich angezogen
und mussten diese Schokolädchen
verteilen.
Ich habe schon damals, mit
neun Jahren, die Schweiz vertreten.
Zu Beginn der Diplomatenausbildung
geht es in verschiedenen Kursen
um das diplomatische Handwerk.
Dazu gehören auch
die richtigen Umgangsformen.
Und genau die lernen sie heute.
Um Punkt 9 Uhr geht es los.
Und Jean-Baptiste?
- Wo ist Jean-Baptiste?
Ah, da ist er, Jean-Baptiste.
Er ist gerade erst
auf dem Weg ins Nobelhotel Bellevue.
Es geht heute um die Etikette,
das Protokoll,
d.h., wie man sich in einem
diplomatischen Umfeld benimmt.
Also die bonnes manieres,
eigentlich.
* Entspannte Klänge *
(Frau)
Sag, wenn du's machst, weil ...
Nein.
- Augen zu.
Sind schon alle weg zum Fototermin.
Du bist zu spät, Jean-Baptiste.
Entschuldigung.
Alle anderen Diplomaten-Stagiaires
sind pünktlich -
beim Etikettenkurs
nicht ganz unwichtig.
Jean-Baptiste hat eine ganz spezielle
Erklärung für seine Verspätung:
... sollte sich fotografieren ...
Du hast gesagt, es war gestern.
Sicher nicht,
ich war gestern gar nicht da.
(Mann) Geht's mit den Augen?
- (Alle) Nein.
* Beschwingte Klänge *
* Stimmengewirr *
Ich war heute früh fast pünktlich.
Aber dann habe ich auf dem Weg
eine Fernseh-Crew getroffen.
Das hat mich ein bisschen verspätet.
Entschuldigung.
Kurz nach 9 Uhr geht es los.
Und es ist klar, welches Thema die
Kursleiterin gleich zu Beginn bringt.
Pünktlichkeit.
Wir haben das gestern Nachmittag
bei den Einladungskarten angeschaut.
Bei einer Einladung zum Essen:
max. 15 Min. später
als die angegebene Zeit -
im westeuropäischen Kontext.
Jetzt gehen wir in das grosse Thema
der Begrüssung.
Man denkt, es sei ein banaler
Händeschlag - ist es aber nicht.
Da kommen wir auch zu Körperausdruck
oder Körpersprache.
(Alle) Oh!
* Lachen *
Wenn ich zu ihm gehe und ihn mit
der Handfläche nach oben begrüsse,
gebe ich bereits bekannt,
wer das Sagen hat.
Es insofern spannend anzuschauen,
dass Herr Putin,
obwohl er physisch nicht
grösser ist als Frau Merkel,
es schafft,
auf sie herunterzuschauen.
Er begrüsst mich jetzt dominant.
Ich mache nun
einen kleinen Schritt nach rechts.
So. Dann dreht sich
die Hand automatisch.
Oh, that's a great pleasure
to meet you.
Very nice to meet you.
- So, how do you do that? Like this?
Mais la, c'est toi qui controle.
Mais on s'est dit,
nous on a plutot l'impression
que c'est l'intensite
qui fait la difference.
* Lachen *
* Lautes Lachen *
Bitte keine Rauch-, Schmink- oder
andere Pausen. Macht das nachher.
Wir gehen alle miteinander
nach unten zum Mittagessen.
Beim Essen werden in der Diplomatie
immer wichtige Themen besprochen.
Die Tischmanieren müssen also sitzen.
Auch das zählt
fürs Bestehen der Ausbildung.
Wir haben beim Mittagessen
einige Hindernisse eingebaut
wie extragrosse Salatblätter
oder auch Spiesse.
Das passiert immer wieder
im Laufe unserer Karriere.
* Angespannte Klänge *
Guten Appetit.
* Lachen *
* Stimmengewirr *
Es ist riesig.
Den kannst du einfach so zerdrücken.
Aber kein Messer.
Messer darf man nicht brauchen?
- Du nimmst das Brot zum Drücken.
Wenn es kein Brot hat,
musst du es irgendwie ...
Dann musst du es zusammenfalten,
genau. Das ist ein bisschen mühsam.
Leider ist es häufiger der Fall als
nicht, dass es solchen Salat gibt.
Ich habe es geschafft,
das abzutrennen. Hurra!
Man darf ...
den Salat nicht schneiden.
Ich glaube, das macht man nicht.
Normalerweise
isst man den Salat mit Brot.
Genau, du hast recht.
Ohne Messer, einfach mit Gabel
und evtl. mit Brot. Das stimmt.
Das habe ich nicht gemacht.
Am Nachmittag
geht es weiter mit Dresscodes,
mit den grossen
Kleider- und Stylingfragen.
Ich denke, ihr kennt das auch.
Unser Gehirn ist zuerst mit den
visuellen Informationen beschäftigt.
Wenn ich zu Ihnen sage,
ich möchte meine Individualität mit
meinen Socken zum Ausdruck bringen,
wie klingt das?
* Lachen *
In der Regel gilt:
je höher die Etage, desto unbunter.
Das hängt aber ehrlich gesagt
sehr von Arbeitsort und Chefs ab.
Aber im Grossen und Ganzen.
Je bunter die Kleidung, desto
niedriger ist die Statusnachricht,
-message oder -botschaft,
die wir übermitteln.
Ja ...
Ich mag Farben.
Ich finde, dass Farbe nichts
mit unprofessionell oder unelegant
zu tun hat.
Vielleicht bin ich auch
noch nicht in der hohen Position,
wo das mega wichtig ist. Aber
ich sehe kein Problem mit Farben.
Ich habe meinen Stil.
Ich finde, das bin ich.
Und ich finde auch, dieser Stil
passt nicht so schlecht ins EDA.
Deshalb bleibe ich jetzt mal dabei.
* Gezupfte Streicherklänge *
Kleider sind für Cristina
nicht nur beruflich wichtig,
sondern auch privat.
Sie näht sehr gerne -
und zwar viele Sachen,
die sie auch als Diplomaten-Stagiaire
anziehen will.
Zu meinen selbstgenähten Sachen habe
ich schon ein besonderes Verhältnis.
Gleichzeitig kenne ich
auch all ihre Schwachstellen.
Ich weiss immer, wo etwas nicht
wie gewünscht funktioniert hat.
Bei dem hier
hat alles ziemlich gut funktioniert.
Ausser vielleicht hier:
Man sieht es nicht gut,
aber die Naht steht auf -
mehr als ich mir gewünscht hätte.
So ...
Mir bedeutet es sehr viel,
deshalb möchte ich auch unbedingt,
dass die Nähmaschine
nach New York mitkommt.
Es ist ein Weg, abzuschalten
und gleichzeitig auch
etwas zu schaffen, kreativ zu sein.
Ich brauche es mittlerweile
fast schon etwas als Ausgleich.
New York, dorthin geht Cristina
für den praktischen Teil
ihrer Diplomatinnen-Ausbildung.
Sie kann unser Land
in der UNO vertreten.
Das passt perfekt
zur studierten Völkerrechtlerin.
Ich habe schon gewisse Ambitionen,
das gebe ich zu.
Ich möchte sicher nicht immer ...
... auf der Stufe
wissenschaftliche Mitarbeiterin
erste diplomatische Mitarbeiterin
sein.
Ich möchte gerne mal
weiter gehen können.
Das ist mit ein Grund, weshalb
ich den Concours gemacht habe.
Im EDA ist es schwierig.
Wenn man nicht Diplomat
oder Diplomatin ist,
ist es schwierig, z.B.
Sektionschefsposten zu übernehmen.
Das gibt es immer wieder, aber das
sind meist sehr, sehr gute Leute.
Und darauf kann man nicht zählen.
Es würde mich schon reizen,
mal ein kleines Team zu führen.
Das fände ich sehr, sehr spannend.
Für den Concours diplomatique
braucht es viel Kraft und Ausdauer.
Gerade New York
gilt innerhalb des Aussendepartements
als eine der strengsten Stationen.
Auch Jean-Baptiste spürt,
wie anspruchsvoll
die Diplomatenausbildung ist.
Mithilfe bei politischen Berichten
oder Organisation
wichtiger Staatsbesuche
gehören zur praktischen Ausbildung.
Es hat in diesem Gebäude
nicht so viel Platz.
Ich habe Glück, dass ich
hier ein Büro bekommen habe
und nicht sonst irgendwo in Bern.
Der Lift ist übrigens superschön.
Ich finde ihn ziemlich charmant.
Ich nehme den Lift
durch die Parlamentsbibliothek
etwa 40-50-mal am Tag.
Ich könnte sportlicher sein
und die Treppe nehmen,
aber nach so viel hin und zurück
ist es ein bisschen angenehmer.
Heute ist ein wichtiger Tag
für Jean-Baptiste.
Er präsentiert heute eine
selbstentwickelte Liste, die zeigt,
mit welchen Ländern
die Schweiz Verträge hat.
Öffnen!
Schau mal!
Die Aussicht ist Wahnsinn.
Nicht filmen,
wie ich die Möbel verschiebe!
Aber die Kabel sind etwas kurz.
Okay, gut.
Diese zwei Jahre
werden wirklich ein Prozess sein.
Ich sehe den Sinn dieser Ausbildung.
Das hat einen Grund.
Diplomatie, diesen Beruf lernt man
nicht mit einem YouTube-Tutorial.
Es braucht Zeit,
man muss bescheiden sein
und ein bisschen Geduld haben.
Ouais.
Gut.
Bonjour. Jean-Baptiste Deleze.
Enchante.
Ah, la seance est ici?
- Oui, tout a fait.
Bonjour, Jean-Baptiste Deleze.
- Daniela Ruppen.
Enchante.
Simon Caduff.
- Simon, enchante.
Mit Burkina Faso haben wir
eine lange Reihe von Abkommen,
viele davon im Bereich Budget ...
Budgethilfe vom SECO.
Kannst du mal zeigen,
wie das mit den Filtern geht?
Das mache ich gleich.
Das geht eigentlich so:
Wenn man den Filter öffnet,
hat man direkt die Liste mit allem,
was unten steht.
Wir hatten auf
unserer Botschaft, auf der ich war,
einen Stagiaire beauftragt,
eine Liste zu machen.
Ich glaube, das wäre
ein gutes Angebot für uns gewesen.
Ich verstehe. Für die Botschaften,
dass sie so etwas nutzen könnten.
Salut, a bientot, ciao.
Merci beaucoup.
Ich bin froh, es lief gut. Die
Stimmung war gut. Es sind Kollegen.
Das finde ich spannend.
Mit 34, mit vorheriger
beruflicher Erfahrung,
beginnst du in diesem Job,
der Diplomatie,
und musst einfach alles neu lernen.
Irgendwie ist es auch
eine Frage des Egos.
Du denkst:
"Ich habe doch schon gearbeitet,
ich habe studiert und so.
Ich kann das schon."
Aber nein. Ich muss
bescheiden sein und mir sagen:
"Hey, nein, das muss ich lernen."
* Kullerende, gläserne Klänge *
Man kann wirklich etwas
für dieses Land leisten.
Das ist die grosse Chance,
die dieser Job bietet.
Dafür brauchen wir Spitzenleute,
und wir versuchen,
Spitzenleute auszuwählen
und dann auszubilden.
Damit wir möglichst die besten
Diplomaten der Welt haben.
* Dumpfe, rhythmische Klänge *
Mit 29 Jahren ist Alexander Scherrer
der Jüngste in der Diplomatenklasse.
Heute ist der Zürcher mit seinen
ehemaligen WG-Mitbewohnern unterwegs.
Jetzt werde ich langsam nervös.
- Kribbelt's? Mal den Puls messen.
Ich glaube,
allzu gefährlich ist es nicht,
aber es sieht schon schwierig aus,
ja.
Man merkt: Wenn er mit etwas Neuem
anfängt, will er es auch können.
Bei jeder Sportart
und auch bei sonstigen Spielen.
Er hat schon seinen Ehrgeiz.
Seid ihr ready?
- Absolut, ja.
Etwas nach hinten!
Ich weiss,
was ich besser machen muss.
Was?
- Mehr nach hinten, hat sie gesagt.
* Entspannte Klänge *
Es ist gut. Ich versuche, etwas zu
drehen, aber das geht noch nicht.
Nach vorne lehnen!
War schön!
Cool!
Erfolg ist Alexander wichtig. Nicht
nur auf dem Surfbrett, auch im Beruf.
Ich hatte
immer wieder im Hinterkopf,
dass es ein extrem spannender Beruf
wäre, der mir zusagen würde.
V.a. gegen Ende Prüfungen, als sich
abzeichnete, dass es möglich ist,
war es schon ein grosses Ziel, ein
grosser Traum, der mich motivierte.
Er hat immer ganz
differenzierte Meinungsbildungen,
bei ihm ist nie etwas
schwarz und weiss.
Er fungiert
auch immer als Vermittler,
führt verschiedene Meinungen zusam-
men und regt so Diskussionen an.
Sicher, Diplomat passt zu 100 %.
Es brauchte schon extremen Ehrgeiz.
Man hat
wirklich etwas schaffen wollen.
Das war, glaube ich,
der Schlüssel für mich,
dass man ...
Dass ich mich von Anfang an
darauf konzentriert
und Schritt für Schritt
genommen habe.
Und dann hatte ich sicher auch etwas
Glück, dass ich reingekommen bin.
* Entspannte elektronische Klänge *
39, yeah, there.
* Verspielte Klänge *
Danke.
- Danke.
Ich liebe diese alten Bahnen.
Die sind so niedlich.
Samira und Edgar sind ein Dream-Team.
Und die Welt ist ihre Heimat.
Sie haben zusammen schon
in Burundi gelebt, jetzt in Bern,
und bald geht es weiter nach Kairo,
wegen Samiras Ausbildung.
Proper holidays for me.
- Exactly.
Für uns ist es wichtig, dass es
ein Projekt für uns beide ist.
Eigentlich ein Familienprojekt.
Es hat für beide wirklich extremen
Einfluss auf unser Leben.
Wir haben das
im Vorfeld lange besprochen
und es entspricht uns beiden,
dieses Leben.
Danke.
- (Mann) Bitte schön.
Auf Wiedersehen, danke.
These are okay.
- Totally.
Regarde, "Kulmli".
That would be our small hut.
These little ... Don't you see ...
- Oh, probably, yeah.
You gotta love it!
- It's so beautiful.
There's nothing typical
about Samira, but ...
Typisch schweizerisch? Für mich
gibt es klare Schweizer Werte.
Gewisse Grundzüge, die er erwähnt
hat: organisiert, pünktlich,
die ganze Vermittlungskultur,
dass man versucht, zwischen ver-
schiedenen Akteuren zu vermitteln.
Das macht für mich
das Schweizerische aus.
* Entspannte Klänge *
Wow!
Tu veux tes lunettes?
- Maybe, yeah.
... les nuages.
- Oh my God, yeah, it just ...
The clouds are so different,
you know.
Zwischen den Wolken geht es
plötzlich um einen neuen Namen.
Alani, um diesen Namen.
Sie wird das Leben von Samira
und Edgar völlig verändern.
Wer Alani ist?
Dazu mehr in der nächsten Folge
von "Die jungen Diplomaten".